♪ ♪ ♪
- J'ai grandi dans un
environnement violent.
♪ ♪ ♪
J'ai appris la colère
et la violence.
- Des fois, ils essaient de fuir
un contexte très violent,
c contexte aussi d'abus.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Elles ont grandi au Nunavik,
un vaste territoire dans le
Grand Nord, que leurs ancêtres
inuks ont apprivoisé
en développant des compétences
de survie exceptionnelles.
Mais on les a brutalement
arrachés à ce mode de vie.
Aujourd'hui, ces beaux paysages
abritent beaucoup de familles
brisées.
Annick, un prénom d'emprunt,
dit qu'elle s'ennuie de la
nourriture et de l'air frais
de son village. La mère de
quatre enfants a quitté
le Nunavik il y a sept mois
avec son bébé.
Elle st t une thérapie pour
traiter son alcoolisme et
apprendre à gérer sa colère.
Elle a fait plusieurs jojours
en prison.
- Certains membres de ma famille
ne me parlent mêmelulus à cause
de ma colère et de mes crises.
J'ai vraiment besoin de changer
de comportement.
♪ ♪ ♪
DAN GAZUT, coordonnateur,
Projets autochtones du Québec
- J'ai pas l'impression d'être
au travail ici, c'est vraiment
beau de voir cette
communauté-là..
- Arrivé de France il y a trois
ans, Dan Gazut a eu le coup
de foudre pour les Premières
Nations.
- C'est des rires, c'est parfois
des moments un peu plus
difficiles qu'on traverse
tous ensemble.
- Il a suivi une formation
pour devenir intervenant
dans ce refuge pour itinérant
autochtone. Presque tous vivent
avec des traumatismeliliés
aux sévices subis par leurs
parents et grands-parents.
- Parfois, les seules choses
où elles trouvent pour survivre
c'est de d'être violent,
d'être dans l'alcoolisme,
la toxicomanie. C'est pas du
tout quelque chose qui vient
comme . . Il y a des raisons,
il y a des traumatismes
derrière. Comme elles ne savent
pas quoi faire d'autre, elles
trtransmettent ça à leurs enfans
et leurs enfants voient... ou
leurs petits-enfants voient que
bien voilà, les adultes, c'est
normal d'êe e comme ça, d'être
violent, d'être intoxiqué,
de ne pas savoir communiquer.
- Quand des Inuks viennent
à Montréal pour des soins de
santé, ils sont pris en charge.
Parfois par un centre de
désintoxication où ici au centre
de santé Ulivi c coincé entre
une autoroute et un parc
industriel à Dorval.
- On a beaucoup à réparer aussi.
- La psychiatre Marie-Ève Cotton
travaille auprès des Inuks
au Nunavik et à Montréal.
Selon elle, le centre Ulivik n'a
pas les ressources
ycychosociales pour encadrer les
patients et leurs traumatismes.
MARIE-ÈVE COTTON, psychiatre
- Ils arrivent à Montréal,
les substances sont plus
accessibles, sont moins chères.
Il y a des gens qui vont leur
en proposer par manipulation
pour essayer de les exploiter,
les rentrer dans des réseaux
de prostitution. Donc, tout ça,
ça peut glisser, ça peut
les amener à la rue.
- Il y a des réseaux de trafic
humain et de trafic sexuel qui
ciblent vraiment spécifiquement
les feeses autochtones et les
femmes inuites en particulier.
- Cette Inuk, qu'on va appeler
Maria, a aussi fui un milieu
violent. Elle n'avait pas encore
cinq ans quand elle a été violée
par un cousin. Malgré tout,
elle a fait des études
collégiales et touchait un bon
salaire en travaillant dans
une mine. Quand elle est arrivée
à Montréal il y a 11 ans,
elle n'a pas trouvé de logement
ni d'emploi.
- Si la discrimination était
moindre envers les autochtones
et les Inuits, je pense que leur
vie serait plus facile et
ils auraient moins de chances
d'aboutir à la rue.
- Prise au piège de réseau
de prostitution, Maria a été
régulièrement frappée, agressée,
mais ce qu'elle a trouvé le plus
difficile, c'est la peur
et le regard des autres.
Des réactions teintées
de préjugés, les femmes inuites
et autochtones en subissent
aussi quand els s ont le courage
d'aller à l'hôpital après
un viol. À Montréal, seulement
deux hôpitaux font des trousses
médico-lalales, nécessaires pour
prouver une agression sexuelle.
LUCIE-CATHERINE OUIMET, infirm.,
Foyer femmes autochtones Mtl
- Dans la rue, moi j'ai
plusieurs patientes que je vois,
qui viennent me voir, elles me
raconte des choses épouvantables
de viol.
- L'infirmière anichinabé,
travaille dans trois refuges
qui hébergent des femmes
autochtones, des projets
cliniques financés
par l'université McGill.
Elle a beaucoup de difficultés
à convaincre ses patientes
d'aller à l'hôpital où le
racisme fait encore des ravages.
- Un des hôpitaux montréalais
qui est désigné a refusé de voir
une de mes patientes, quététait
pourtant accompagnée de deux
de mes étudiantes francophones,
parce que la patiente ne parlait
pas français. C'est arrivé.
- Pensez-vous e e c'est la vraie
raison?
- L'impressionu'u'on a eue,
c'est parce qu'elle était
autochtone. Puis elle était
en état d'intocacation.
(chants autochtones)
- Sept mois de sobriété. Je suis
fière de moi. Je pensais ne
jamais réussir à devenir sobre,
à gérer mes émotions.
- Maria n'est pas complètement
sombre, mais elle a fait assez
de progrès pour être admise
en logement de transition.
Ces deux femmes ne souhaitent
pas retourner nsns leur
communauté, où elles risquent de
retrouver des milieux toxiques.
Elles rêvent toutes les deux
d'aider d'autres femmes inuks
et autochtones à s'en sortir.
- J'ai moi-même vécu beaucoup
d'épreuves, j'aimerais les aider
à avoir une v m meilleure
que la mienne.
♪ ♪